before the movie unfolds we're presented
with brief information about the
afterlife according to Buddhist
scriptures souls are judged seven times
in 49 days for their Earthly vices of
Deceit indolence Injustice betrayal
violence murder and filial impiety only
those who pass the trials are allowed to
reincarnate straight in the first scene
we thrust into the thick of the action
as firefighter Kim yahan leaps through a
burning window he cradles a young girl
in his arms desperate to hand her off to
his colleague on a safety trolley
tragedy strikes when the Rope sever
sending Kim plummeting with the child
still clutch tightly miraculously he
absorbs the impact of the Fall shielding
the girl from harm waking up from the
fall Kim is relieved to see the girl as
well and alive he sigh and is glad to be
alive as the fall could potentially have
killed both of them bewildered he scans
his surroundings and sees two figures
dressed in black standing nonchalantly
near the falling debris he goes to warn
them but suddenly Witnesses a disturbing
scene his lifeless body lies mere feet
away his colleagues frantically
attempting to revive him the two figures
introduce themselves as Guardians of the
afterlife tasked with defending Kim in
his upcoming trials the man announces
himself as Deputy guardian hewan and the
girl as assistant Guardian deok Chun
their leader and the third Guardian
gangam is at Kim's funeral home as per
the protocol the bubbly assistant
Guardian diakun informs Kim of his rare
and honorable death as a paragon with a
glimmer of hope she assures him of his
reincarnation within 49 days overwhelmed
by the sight of his own death Kim
desperately begs for a final moment with
his mother but the rules of the
afterlife demand his immediate departure
meanwhile the third Guardian gangam
enjoys a meal at Kim's funeral home he
observes Kim's brother fresh from his
mandatory military service urging their
mother to attend the casing ceremony of
his deceased brother our scene then
shifts to the crowded Gates of the
afterlife where thousands of souls await
their judgment he one guides Kim before
the imposing statue of King yomra the
Lord of afterlife and introduces him to
gangam as the guard Guardian who has
successfully reincarnated 47 souls in
the past Century as they approach the
gate deun proudly displays Kim's Paragon
card marking the official commencement
of his trials to he1 as shock the gate
unexpectedly leads them straight to the
hell of murder he questions Kim but the
firefighter adamantly denies ever
harming anyone gangam explains that King
Yer determines the order of the trials
proceeding from the lightest to the
heaviest and even indirect harm can
trigger a trial as they prepare to
defend Kim de Chun scans the list of
charges against him using her unique
ability suddenly the ground around Kim
cracks open revealing the terrifying
volcano of death screams pierce the air
as Unfortunate Souls drenched in molten
lava struggle to climb its treacherous
slopes Kim stands accused of indirectly
causing the death of a colleague who
perished during a fire in front of the
god of murder two prosecutors claim Kim
prioritized his own safety over his
colleagues despite having ample time to
rescue him they demand a harsh sentence
of 5 years in the fiery death deps of
the volcano undeterred gang liim steps
forward to defend Kim he unveils Vivid
memories of that fateful day on the
mirror of karma showcasing Kim's Valiant
efforts to save his colleague however
the colleague understanding the dire
situation urged Kim to prioritize the
lives of civilians trapped in the
burning building with a heavy heart Kim
followed his colleagues wishes and
rescued eight innocent lives but
tragically he was unable to reach his
friend before the building collapsed the
judge faced with the impossible task of
judging the valley of One Life against
another ultimately acquits Kim
recognizing that Kim saved eight lives
that day with the hell of murder behind
them the three Guardians embark on a
boat Journey to the hell of indolence
where Kim will be judged on whether he
lived his life to its true potential or
he wasted his time lazing around
confident of an easy trial gang liim
cautions Kim about the prosecutor's
ambition to secure their own promotion
through his conviction Kim curious about
the Guardians motives inquires about
their purpose theune reveals their pact
with King Yom successful Reincarnation
of 49 Souls within a century unlocks
their own reincarnation as their boat
Glides forward ganglin delivers one
final warning do not talk back to the
goddess of indolence the trial unfolds
and deun skillfully showcases Kim's
dedication highlighting his tireless
efforts to save both humans and animals
impressed by his deeds the benevolent
goddess embodied as a wise grandmother
swiftly acquits Kim however her
subsequent question about his motivation
for working Sparks and misunderstanding
in Kim's innocent reply about earning
money is misinterpreted by the goddess
as worshiping the god of money facing
imminent punishment for his perceived
Devotion to the wrong deity Kim floats
towards a chilling waterfall where
countless Souls suffer in Terror just as
his fate seems sealed gangam intervenes
through Vivid memories showcased on the
mirror of karma he reveals the truth
Kim's multiple jobs Beyond his
firefighting duties were driven by money
to support his sick mother and his
brother's lost school education
recognizing Kim's genuine desire to use
his hard work for Noble purposes the
goddess reverses her decision and grants
him a quiddle leaving the hell of
indolence behind the Guardians lead Kim
to the treacherous blade Forest where
the trial of Deceit awaits he one
reveals that if Kim simply follows gang
lm's orders he may get the chance to
visit his mother in a dream before he is
reincarnated hearing this a visibly
emotional Kim becomes more focused on
the tasks at hand as they navigate the
blade Forest on a speeding boat
something weird begins to happen to
afterlife the atmosphere darkens time
accelerates and without warning
monstrous creatures launch a surprise
attack the Guardians bravely fend off
the assault revealing that such
disturbances happen when a Living member
of a soul dies with a grudge and becomes
a vengeful Spirit a worried Kim fears
his mother's possible demise the octune
blindfolds Kim in preparation for his
trial while he1 delivers a grim warning
the vengeful Spirits Havoc threatens to
derail Kim's progress jeopardizing his
chance to reach the final trial within
the 49-day deadline to prevent this
ganglin makes a daring decision he will
return to the living world and
investigate the source of the vengeful
spirit's anger in the realm of the
living gangam encounters Kim's brother
suong consumed by resentment suhong
Harbors a deep Grudge further fueled by
his mother's grief and her Continued
Care for his deceased brother's
possessions this anger festers within
him ultimately transforming him into a
vengeful Spirit gangam desperately
chases after suhong but the enraged
Spirit easily outruns him back in the
blade Forest a Restless Kim seizes an
opportunity when he one isn't looking he
removes his blindfold and pleads with
diakun for news of his mother theak Chun
deep in a trans as she scans potential
charges against him is abruptly awakened
by the approach of menacing hell ghouls
their presence is a direct consequence
of Kim's Disobedience fortunately they
are saved by the unexpected arrival of
King y himself though relieved they
receive a Stern message for gang Lam the
vengeful Spirit must be neutralized
quickly King Yom demands the dead body
be burned and the spirit banished or he
will personally descend and handle the
matter himself as the next trial Begins
the goddess of Deceit appears in the
form of a young girl gleefully enjoying
a colorful candy the accusations are
harsh Kim stands charged with crafting
98 false letters to families of accident
victims among them is jaon the young
daughter of Kim's deceased colleague
trapped under Rubble during a fire the
prosecutors highlight the emotional pain
inflicted upon jaon who clung to hope
for her father despite knowing the truth
stunned into silence Kim faces the
threat of having his tongue severed by
the angry goddess just in time gangam
establishes a mental connection with
deok Chun allowing him to defend Kim
through deak Chun gangam admits Kim's
deception the numerous fabricated
letters written to various individuals
including his own mother while these
letters created a false reality of a
happy married life for himself they also
served a purpose his mother fueled by
hope found the strength to overcome her
illness and make a full recovery
likewise the letters offered jaon father
motherless and grieving a spark of hope
that allowed her to continue her studies
recognizing that the benefits of Kim's
lies outweighed the harm the goddess of
Deceit acquits him as they leave the
blade Forest Kim expresses his yearning
to see his mother revealing his
heartfelt purchase an electric rice
cooker to assist her with dementia yakun
then confirms her knowledge of a hidden
letter tucked within the rice cooker a
message from Kim to his mother back in
the world of the living gangam assumes
the role of a lieutenant colonel to
investigate Su Hong's death at the
military base he grills Lieutenant Park
who reveals suhong as a capable officer
admired by his men however gang liim
suspects a hidden truth beneath Park's
words digging deeper gangam uncovers a
fateful night when suhan and Dong yon
stood guard together fearful of upcoming
discharge dong yon was worried about
facing his bullies without Su Hong's
protection suhan reassured him promising
to check on him and ensure Lieutenant
Park's support in a moment of
anxiousness dong yon accidentally shot
Suh Han but Suh Han still alive pleaded
with dong yon to call Lieutenant Park
terrified of losing his promotion LT
Park opted for a cover up burying suhong
with dong yon's assistance unbeknownst
to both suong was still alive in that
moment and their actions sealed Suh
Hong's fate gangam realizes that suhong
Harbors resentment towards dong yon and
park not his brother he retrieves the
buried body prioritizing a proper burial
over incineration a decision that
displeases he won in the afterlife Kim
bypasses trials in the hells of
Injustice and betrayal due to to his
noble character however the afterlife
World continues to suffer under the
influence of his brother's vengeful
Spirit meanwhile gangam tracks down a
drunken dongon at a club he Witnesses
Suh Hong's Spirit attempting to kill him
using a disco light dangum intervenes
and manages to capture the spirit he
explains how Suh Han's actions are
jeopardizing his brother's trials but
receives a shocking Revelation suhan
Harbors hatred towards his brother never
having met him after Kim ran away from
home 15 years ago later a drunk dong y
returns to where Suh Han's mother lives
and throws in a map leading to the
buried body both the spirit and his
mother watch in disbelief as the map
unfolds its Secrets driven to despair
dong yon attempts suicide by hanging
himself witnessing this tragic scene
gang liim is approached by su Han's
Spirit who begs him to save Don Yan's
life in exchange suhong promises
complete obedience despite the potential
consequences of meddling in the Affairs
of the Living World gang liim
reluctantly agrees to intervene assuming
a tangible form gangam appears before
dong yon using words channeled from
suong he offers forgiveness and
encourages dong yon to never ever waste
new tears on past mistakes a phrase that
suong had told dong yon before a sense
of relief washes over suong allowing him
to accompany gang Lim in retrieving his
body for proper burial and passage to
the afterlife however the repercussions
of gang Lim's interference become
evident in the hell of violence instead
of the expected shallow descent Kim
faces a tumultuous and lengthy fall they
finally reach before the king of
violence where the prosecutors unveil
shocking accusations they portray Kim as
a brutal high school bully relentlessly
tormenting his malnourished younger
brother suhan the king acknowledges
Kim's failure to apologize or reconcile
with his family further noting the
connection between this case and Kim's
final trial unmoved by Polie the god of
violence readily sentences Kim to
immediate punishment much to the
prosecutor's Delight with options
dwindling he one desperately contacts
gangam who is at the burial site in a
desperate attempt to save Kim's life
gang liim suggests a combined trial this
risky maneuver will merge the current
trial of violence with the trial of
filial impiety if Kim loses he faces a
doubled sentence and even the Guardians
risk losing their privileges in the
afterlife as they Journey Through the
vast desert towards the hell of filial
impiety deok Chun delves into a trance
scanning the charges against Kim to her
horror she uncovers a chilling truth on
the night of his Escape Kim attempted to
murder his own mother by suffocating
ating her with a pillow his shocking
confession reveals A desperate plan to
end his own life his brothers and their
mothers due to their crushing poverty
and his mother's illness he admits to
attempting to suffocate his mother
before overdosing himself and his
brother but his attempt was thwarted by
his younger brother Suh Han this
confrontation explains the god of
violence's earlier observation
connecting the two cases back in the
world of the living suhan now free from
his vengeful Spirit seeks refuge in his
physical body before departing for the
afterlife gang Lim instructs him to
visit the army base there they witness
his mother desperately searching for his
body holding a placard pleading for help
fearing the Potential Threat this poses
to his promotion Lieutenant Park
ruthlessly pushes the old woman forcing
her into an ambulance witnessing this
act of Cruelty reignites Suh Han's
vengeful Spirit unleashing a devastating
tornado that engulfs the entire base
consuming everything and everyone in its
path including Lieutenant Park the
repercussions of this violent act Ripple
into the Afterlife as the sand monsters
attack dechun he and Kim recognizing the
danger gang limb faces he one opens a
portal transporting himself to the
Mortal realm where he confronts the now
immensely powerful Spirit fueled by the
anger of witnessing his mother's assault
however a fleeting moment of hesitation
arises when suong sees Kim struggling
for his life in the afterlife buried
under sand seizing this opportunity
ganglin binds suong reverting him to his
human form and bringing the destructive
tornado to a halt the moment the tornado
Subs Ides a vast Hall materializes
around the desert in the afterlife it is
the imposing hell of filial impiety with
King y himself priding over the final
trial with a Stern demeanor King y
accuses Kim of attempting to murder his
mother and brutally assaulting his
younger brother who is suffering from
malnutrition without granting him the
right to defend himself King Yer
declares Kim guilty and sentences him to
a lifetime of Torment in how however
deak Chun defies protocol she
emotionally appeals to King yomra
revealing that Kim mother was asleep and
unaware of his intentions she emphasizes
that Kim despite fleeing the scene lived
a life of hardship and sacrifice
striving to provide for his brother and
mother in a shocking turn King y uses
the mirror of karma to reveal a
heartbreaking truth Kim's mother Fain
sleep silently witnessing his actions
and bearing the pain in her heart the
Revelation crushes Kim Who falls to his
knees pleading for punishment in
exchange of one last chance to see his
mother as the prosecutors pronounce the
harsh verdict for Kim's crimes of filial
impiety and violence the Afterlife
trembles with seismic disturbances
hinting at someone meddling in the world
of the living in an unexpected move gang
Lim grants suhan the ability to enter
his mother's dream defying King y's
Authority in the dream realm suhan
reveals to his mother his success as a
respected judge and shares how Kim
sacrificed his life to provide for them
in a miraculous event Kim's mother
Speaks For the First Time absolving both
her sons of any wrongdoing she expresses
regret for not being a better better
mother and Embraces suong in forgiveness
this active forgiveness in the world of
the living altars the course of the
afterlife trial King Yer declares Kim
acquitted acknowledging that a sin
forgiven in the living realm cannot be
judged in the afterlife liberated from
his charges Kim embarks on his
reincarnation the ever benevolent
ganglin delivers the electric rice
cooker with Kim's letter a final gift to
his mother as the movie reaches its
final scene gang Lim realizes the truth
when he was rescuing suhong from his
vengeful Spirit In The Living World King
om had been continuously testing him
disguised as he won tempting him with
alternative choices now alongside suhan
another Paragon Soul the three Guardians
head on a journey to confront King yra
ready for the next chapter in their
afterlife